ministre démissionnaire laissé seul
pendant 20 minutes attendre son
remplacant une scène à l'image du
malaise créé par le départ de gérard
collomb il restera toujours une petite
part de vous donc
car si c'est officiellement pour devenir
maire de lyon il quitte ministère de
l'intérieur personne n'est dupe en fait
le courant ne passait plus entre lui et
le premier ministre entre lui et le
président une conséquence directe de la
sphère benalla ce collaborateur d'
emmanuel macron qui s'était fait passer
pour un policier au mois de mai pour
tabasser les manifestants
regardez bien cette étude a tabassé par
terre je condamne avec la plus grande
fermeté les actes de monsieur benalla
avec cette émission
emmanuel macron perd l'un de ses
premiers soutiens l'un de ses plus
fidèles lieutenants
celui qui avait versé une larme lors de
son investiture
un départ qui témoigne surtout d'un
profond problème dans la maison macron
car c'est le septième ministre à
démissionner le troisième on appelle
plus d'un mois avec entre autres le
départ fracassant du ministre de
l'environnement nicolas hulot c'est
révélateur d'un malaise parce que les
démissionnaires ont critiqué la façon de
gouverner d'emmanuel macron le ministre
de l'intérieur lui reproche le manque
d'humilité l'aurait pris la grosse tête
en quelque sorte depuis qu'il est
président en quelques mois le président
a multiplié les erreurs de communication
des petites phrases qui passe mal auprès
de l'opinion
le faire l'imbécile
oui c'est la marseillaise et le chant
des partisans je m'appelle monsieur le
président explique monsieur conséquence
un an et demi après son élection
monsieur le président bat des records
d'impopularité avec 28% seulement
d'opinions favorables 28 % c'est un
niveau de satisfaction qui me met au
même niveau que françois hollande à la
même époque
or françois hollande a été le président
le plus impopulaire quasiment durant
tout son mandat de la vème république
une chute vertigineuse pour un homme qui
était vu au moment de son élection comme
un enfant prodige comme un sauveur
ce qui est le plus inquiétant pour
emmanuel macron c'est que au delà de la
simple cote de popularité ce qui a pu
changer c'est la perception de lui les
français
s'il ya un an encore 68% d'entre eux le
trouvais plutôt sympathique
aujourd'hui sept français sur dix le
trouve autoritaire et arrogant ici jean
françois bélanger radio canada